dis moi finalement thouars était un
cynique pas vous savez un dans une
société d'hypocrites le cynisme fini par
être le compte de la franchise ben oui
est ce que tu as déjà pensé à se
suicider le suicide c'est l'acte
désespéré d'un être qui ne fait plus
confiance ni à la guerre ni aux
transports ni aux maladies nyala nature
autre chose et tu favorable à
l'abolition de la peine de mort
l'abolitionnisme c'est une mesure que
l'on a prises pour qu'un crime ne fasse
pas chaque fois deux morts et tu penses
quoi de l'évolution du métier de
journaliste ce que tu es journaliste je
crois en toi bouffe l'aurait beaucoup
pas dire mais bon faute de temps le
journaliste moderne doit choisir où
voire l'événement où le décrire il a
rarement le loisir de faire les deux je
suppose qu'il ya 20 ans tu voulais faire
la révolution
oui ben comme tous ceux qui ont 20 ans
puis après
bon bah quand on s'aperçoit qu'une
révolution n'abolit pas les privilèges
mais qu'elles se bornent à changer les
privilégiés et tu penses quoi de l'amour
tarifé bas beaucoup de bien parce que
les prostituées sont des dames qui ne
demande pas qu'on les invite à dîner
avant de passer à l'acte puis honneur à
la main d'oeuvre qualifiée
tout le monde parle de racisme mais pour
toi c'est quoi au juste le racisme basta
la fois un sentiment bas et un sentiment
en pratique puisque ça consiste à en
vouloir à des gens qui sont aisément
repérables qui généralement sont plus
malheureux que soi
si tu devais donner une définition de la
civilisation
ben je dirais que selon qu'on se met un
anneau
dans le nez ou dans l'oreille on est un
sauvage ou civilisé as tu peur de mourir
face qui m'embête c'est que la mort
empêche d'aller à ces rendez vous du
lendemain crois tu re l'existence de
dieu
non dieu n'existe pas enfin il faut
faire semblant d'y croire parce que ça
lui fait tellement plaisir
les corrections de ne rien rater de
minardi tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux